speaking of terrible people here is
cringe
Jean-Pierre she was doing one of her
little press secretary things that she
pretends to do over there at the White
House and uh she was asked because Biden
himself Joe Biden himself a tweet that
he put out now obviously Joe Biden is
not allowed to hold the phone he
probably doesn't even know what Twitter
is he you know they're just somebody
else is doing it but Joe Biden's Twitter
account put out a tweet that was fact
checked by Twitter and cringe was asked
about it the president had a tweet out
last night saying that real wages for
the average an American worker have are
higher than they were for the
the Tweet has now been annotated with a
message from the platform saying that
that is not
advanced
they have some some stats and some
charts uh footnoted along with that do
you welcome that um kind of contestation
from Tech platforms you disagree
do you have any any but we disagree
because if we're looking at the data
from uh from February of 2021 and what
we've seen is that wages have have
gotten stronger have increased we've
seen that by neck economic Dynamics has
been really helpful in getting to make
sure that we build an economy that
leaves no one behind well we just
disagree with the backtrackers we just
make up numbers sort of like we do
something called the inflation reduction
act which actually just means we print a
whole bunch of money which actually
causes inflation but we put reduction
right in the title of it so you don't
really have to think about it do you
which really just gets us to the uh the
nice linchpin of everything that I've
done for the first 20 minutes of today's
program a simple line by Joe Biden when
he was campaigning when he actually did
tell the truth
we choose Unity over division we choose
science over fiction we choose truth
over facts you know we're living in a
society
we choose truth over facts we choose
truth over facts they make up something
that's true and they choose it over
facts I do accept that
thank you
[Music]